we always talk about this early level of
culture as hunting-gathering
and I think that we drop our voices we
say it's a hunting-gathering culture if
you've spent time in the Amazon you know
that what this means is once a month or
once every six weeks the men get their
act sufficiently together and they make
up enough coca that they all go get
their supposin arrows and they go off
for a hunt and leave the women and the
children behind and get all coked up and
hunt and party all night and then when
the coca is all gone because usually
women make the coca when the coca is all
gone whatever they've captured on the
hunt
they triumphantly carry back to the
village and often you know it's garbage
and the women will be waiting at the
village for them to come back and say
you know eight days in the woods and you
bring back one maggoty a booty you know
what kind of clowns are you people but
this is the huns you know and the hunter
is the hero and they'll tell the story
around the campfire meanwhile what is
really going on as is always the case
is that women are gathering
and gathering is a highly conscious
activity where you know this plant is
okay that plant is bad the root of this
plant is poisonous but if pound will
pounded with water and washed it becomes
edible it's in it's an intelligence an
activity that demands discrimination
intelligence a body of lore
memory powers of observation so forth
and so on it is in fact the serious
business while this hunting thing exists
almost to keep the men out of the
woman's hair
[Music]
you